[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Karine grattecamp
présidente de l'association Hadès 78 et
Didier de gueuse vice-président de
l'association bonjour alors vous êtes
donc président et vice-président enfin
présidente pardon et vice-président de
l'association départementale pour
l'éducation spécialisée des enfants
déficients auditifs pour adeda alors
quelle est l'histoire de l'association
c'est une association qui a été créée en
1984 par Madame Faivre a débuté un peu
en 1983
elle est issue madame fèves est une
maman qui avait une perce un enfant qui
était difficile et qu'il avait aucune
structure pour prendre son enfant au
sein des Yvelines progressivement à la
constitué un dossier pour créer cette
association quel jour à 84 à carrière
sous Poissy
avec trois quatre parents bénévoles et
au début elle a pris en charge 5 enfants
avec que des orthophonistes en tant que
professionnel ensuite cette association
a évoluée elle a pris de plus en plus
d'enfants alors apprenez les enfants de
0 à 12 ans
donc spécifiquement sur le primaire et
après la création du site de carrière
sous Poissy un autre site toujours pour
le même catégorie d'enfants a été créé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et maintenant
situé à Guyancourt dans la continuité
bien des années après on s'est aperçu
que il y avait d'un besoin de suivi de
ses enfants en secondaire donc on a créé
un service de secondaire qui est
maintenant situé à Guyancourt et on
prend en charge donc ces enfants de
d'après la primaire jusqu'à ses 20 ans
et ça va jusqu'au du collège jusqu'au
lycée et donc aujourd'hui voilà vous
accompagner les enfants de 0 à 20 ans
quels sont les objectifs justement de
l'association au quotidien
les objectifs c'est l'intégration des
statuts l'intégration sociale et
scolaire d'un enfant malentendant
l'objectif c'est que de prendre en
charge ses enfants les emmener vers le
réalisation et ensuite
qui sont très au mieux dans leur milieu
scolaire leur milieu familial de leur
milieu professionnel alors l'Inclusion
Scolaire a fait débat lors de la
campagne présidentielle en 2022 certains
candidats étaient pour alors que
d'autres souhaitaient surtout placer les
enfants situation de handicap dans des
établissements spécialisés alors
qu'est-ce qu'apporte l'inclusion
scolaire aux enfants déficients auditifs
j'aimerais juste déjà enfin préciser
enfin il y a pas autant de clivages dans
le champ du handicap effectivement il y
a des enfants qui peuvent totalement
inclus et des enfants pour lesquels
l'inclusion n'est pas possible donc il
faut effectivement qu'il soit placé en
institution et puis pour d'autres ou
c'est un petit peu entre les deux c'est
un peu compliqué mais l'inclusion il est
certain apporte énormément à l'enfant
surtout à l'enfant sourd parce que le
but pour l'emmener vers cette inclusion
c'est d'acquérir le français aura les
écrit et si on n'est pas baigné dans une
langue on ne peut pas on peut pas
avancer donc effectivement les enfants
qui sont suivis à la desa sont tous à
parier ou implantés donc ils entendent
on va dire mais de la compréhension
c'est un autre sujet mais effectivement
l'inclusion apporte énormément ils ne
sont pas on dit souvent dans leur bulle
enfin voilà ils sont on les ouvre à tout
à toutes les possibilités et même aussi
aux parents on ouvre cette possibilité
là mais je dis moi voilà je modère
toujours de le propos parce que
l'inclusion oui mais pas à tort et à
travers faut que celle-ci soit faite
dans les bonnes conditions faut donner
les moyens aussi aux familles de pouvoir
le faire aussi aux enseignants de
pouvoir le faire parce que on voit
qu'effectivement il y a il y a un
discours politique qui est là mais les
effets derrière on va dire sont un peu
moindres
voilà donc inclusion oui ça apporte
énormément et c'est essentiel c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui nos enfants il y a
quelques années on va dire il y a 10 ans
20 ans 30 ans n'aurait pas espéré
pouvoir faire des études supérieures et
maintenant peuvent aller jusqu'aux
études supérieures un champ plus large
de métier qui s'ouvre à eux parce que si
le meilleur visibilité l'inclusion c'est
ça aussi c'est rendre visible le
handicap qui n'est pas forcément visible
ou qu'on veut cacher et ça c'est c'est
essentiel enfin je pense que si demain
dans toutes les classes de France et de
Navarre on a fait
il y avait un enfant en situation
d'handicap on se poserait moins de
questions sur comment on fait pour plus
tard comment voilà donc je pense que
c'est c'est
ces matières à débat c'est sûr mais en y
mettant les moyens humains et financiers
une volonté derrière mais de faire
vraiment des choses comme elle devrait
être faite c'est-à-dire pas non plus à
tort et à travers on arriverait quelque
chose vraiment de super mais bon il est
pas encore justement donc l'enfant est
accompagné pendant sa scolarité par des
par des professionnels comment se passe
cet accompagnement et comment est-il
est-il mis en place parce qu'on imagine
que chaque enfant a des besoins
particuliers des besoins surtout
différents ben en fait nous elle a des a
les enfants arrivent généralement suite
à un diagnostic de surdité c'est simple
et les parents doivent constituer un
dossier MDPH alors ça on est vraiment
sur du côté administratif pur et dur
sont aussi les parents n'ont beaucoup de
cheminement diagnostics médicaux enfin
voilà de bilan médico et compagnie et
quand enfin ils arrivent à la Desda
euh
nous demande aux parents ben que
souhaitez-vous pour votre enfant
généralement effectivement quand les
parents arrivent chez nous c'est ben ils
veulent que leur enfant on réalise parce
que voilà il veut pas partir sur de la
langue des signes où ils veulent
vraiment une inclusion par le
réalisation donc déjà c'est un projet ça
que les parents ont en commun quand avec
la désaccord quand ils viennent et puis
après ben voilà on travaille à au
souhait vraiment des parents
et puis aux capacités aussi de l'enfant
parce que comme vous l'avez dit chacun
est différent j'avais besoin différent
mais voilà c'est c'est des des
adaptations qui sont faites en fait
chaque année chaque année des bilans qui
sont faits que les parents les
professionnels les rencontres pour juste
que toute façon jusqu'en primaire toute
la les années primaire c'est une
rencontre hebdomadaire avec
l'orthophoniste avec les professionnels
qui entourent l'enfant pour vraiment
être au plus proche de de son évolution
de ses besoins
et et aller justement sur est-ce que
l'inclusion est-elle possible
l'inclusion en école de quartier est-ce
qu'on prend un dispositif Ulysse donc
c'est de l'inclus enfin c'est un
dispositif voilà d'éducation nationale
qui qui
est là pour pouvoir proposer aux enfants
une scolarité un peu plus adaptée et
puis sinon de dire aux parents bah non
la scolarisation n'est pas possible il
faudra voir autre chose mais voilà on
essaye de effectivement de répondre aux
besoins les plus
quand ils sont petits c'est les besoins
les plus primaires j'ai envie de dire
c'est apprendre à oraliser et après on
va dire que au fur et à mesure qu'il
grandissent qu'ils sont pris en charge
au niveau de leur scolarité les besoins
sont plus les mêmes on va travailler la
lecture on va travailler
ça je vous parle pour le travail de
l'orthophoniste vraiment tout ce qui est
des apprentissages autour de la
grammaire de l'orthographe mais à côté
de ça il y a aussi des prises en charge
psychologiques il y a aussi une
éducatrice spécialisée qui travaille en
groupe sur groupe ou en individuel mais
généralement en groupe sur justement
c'est unifier ses enfants voilà ne pas
qu'il ne reste pas tout seul dans leur
coin et puis qui s'ouvre aux autres il y
a aussi de la psychomotricité parce que
certains peuvent avoir des difficultés
ne serait-ce qu'avec leur corps avec
leur handicap ou des difficultés
d'équilibre lié forcément à la surdité
donc voilà tout ça c'est c'est un
maillage c'est qui est fait avec la
famille en lien avec la famille les
équipes pluridisciplinaires et ensuite
l'enfant comme ça
accompagner l'enfant mais vous
accompagnez vous soutenez également la
famille les parents
quand on dit effectivement qu'on
accompagne un jeune on accompagne pas
que le jeûne on accompagne la famille et
on prend aussi en compte les fratries
les parents et voilà c'est vraiment dans
un
on prend tout le monde en fait c'est pas
juste un enfant et ses oreilles c'est un
enfant avec sa problématique de
d'handicap et Ben et on va dire j'ai
envie de dire le le tsunami que ça peut
engendrer dans une famille quand on sous
le coup d'un diagnostic c'est ça peut
être compliqué alors justement j'ai deux
petites questions alors déjà où sont
situés vos locaux comment est-ce qu'on
peut vous vous rencontrer est-ce que
vous allez participer ou en tout cas
organiser des événements pour cette
année 2023 pour venir à la rencontre
justement des citoyens et parents ayant
des enfants déficients auditifs
on a trois sites on a deux sites qui
prennent les enfants entre en primaire
entre 0 et 12 ans Nike est situé à
Poissy et un autre trappe
et on a un troisième site qui prend en
charge secondaire tout ce qui est
secondaire donc du collège au lycée qui
lui est à Guyancourt donc pour contacter
adesda c'est par téléphone
et on est on a un site également
internet qui est
refondation actuellement
pour qu'il soit un peu plus
accessible entre guillemets aux
personnes qui feraient des recherches
et en termes de projet alors
pour se faire reconnaître connaître on a
un projet festif qui va arriver en 2024
qui seront les 40 ans de la désa
catégorie en 1984 et cette occasion donc
on va faire sûrement quelque chose de
très festif avec les parents les anciens
etc et je pense qu'on va aller un peu
plus loin effectivement pour se faire
connaître un peu plus auprès des
autorités de tutelle auprès des
partenaires des partenaires les mairies
les radios les médias et tout ça pour
pour les familles qui ont justement un
enfant ou plusieurs enfants voilà
déficients déficients auditif merci
beaucoup Karine gratte-caffé Didier de
gusze d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation donc pour plus d'informations
on peut se rendre sur ads.fr et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]